now the Tim Burton's remake is all but
forgotten watch the Planet of the Apes
movies reclaim their place as the best
talking animal franchise since babe dawn
of the Planet of the Apes wait why does
dawn come after rise don't you rise
after the dawn whatever settle in for
the thinking man's summer blockbuster
chock full of complicated characters
political maneuvering family dynamics
and a monkey dual wielding machine guns
on horseback fighting a tank
okay that was kind of dumb who cares
it's still awesome right thrill as Apes
engage in guerrilla warfare against a
society of way less interesting humans
like the pragmatic leader who spends
most of his screen time talking into a
bullhorn
this generic good guy this act all
handmade this woman and this kid who
draws things yeah let's get back to the
Apes see Andy Serkis delivering
oscar-worthy performance by capturing
the graceful movements and emotions of
Caesar and doing his best Christian Bale
Batman impression once I made while the
cast and crew delivering even more
oscar-worthy performance by not laughing
at a tiny British man in a unitard
pretending to be a monkey man when you
take away the CGI this looks [ __ ]
ridiculous
so immerse yourself in a movie full of
stunning visuals and great acting that
will have audiences everywhere ignoring
it's forgettable plot about fixing a
damn city used to run off nuclear power
but that ran out years ago so we've been
using diesel generators and gasifiers
but if we can just get this dam working
blah blah blah blah and the super cliche
death of the main villain
because once again Aves with guns on
horseback equals awesome story MVP most
valuable primate little caesar's abu
mojo jojo not hairy old man discount
Charlton Heston April O'Neil and damn
dirty Apes actually they're pretty clean
and civilized and damn civilized Apes
rise of the dawn of the start of the
Planet of the Apes origins the beginning
so uh how can I put this um where are
the monkey dicks be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers
I love CaptainSparklez
hello I just pooped my pants you lewd
crude rude beg a preachy food dude screw
the rules
I have money gotta go fast in Soviet
Russia Waldo finds you you will be
exterminated
exterminate